[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on
Dana hi uh so I I am 29 years old and
I've been planning to purchase a home
but I'm planning to like purchase it
with my brother so is it a smart idea to
like have my brother as a co-owner of
the property I mean majority of the down
payment is going to come from me and so
is mortgage yeah no um Noe nope nope no
how old did you say you
were I'm 29 29 29 okay why can I just
can I understand why why are you guys
doing this together what's the purpose
in your
mind um we've been living together um
like for like three years and we've been
planning to purchase a
property as well why is my question
um because well we just we we we're like
both single and we don't know like we
wanted to stop renting and we wanted to
have like our own property so this is
your way you felt like you couldn't
afford it separately so you're doing it
together is that
accurate uh yes I think I mean
personally I like with the current
housing market I don't think I can
afford like the monthly mortgage well
let's look at it what do you make every
what do you make every month what's your
take- home pay I make uh around every
month yeah yeah around 6 6200
6,200 yes that's your take home pay okay
so what type of home are you trying to
buy like when you when you say here's
what I need and you're realistic about
what your needs are and you're not going
overboard what was what does a cost a
home like that cost you in Los Angeles
because I know it's going to be
expensive yeah um since I'm single like
maybe like a condo or a town house like
with like two bed like a single bedroom
like I'm just like living alone sure
that's fair enough what what would that
cost you in the area that you
live um in the area you're trying to be
looking it's yeah it's around like 450
to five 5 I think no I 450 to 600 okay
so 450 to 600 that's a big range um and
then my next question is what kind of
work do you
do I work in a as a lab scientist in a
hospital
a lab scientist okay here's thanks for
giving me the particulars I don't think
that you should like John said I don't
think that you should buy a home with
your brother there's a lot that can go
wrong there um it would be different if
one of you were purchasing the home and
one of you put the down payment on and
said hey if you want to live here and
pay me rent or pay for your room here
you could do that um doing that yeah
that's that's fine um the the hard part
comes
when it's you're dating somebody and
you're ready for them to move out and
now they feel like they got the raw end
of the deal like there are many things
that can go wrong and I just want to
call that out so and and there's one
other thing when you're married there's
a and you get divorced there is a
business there's a legal path towards
separation it's why we same reason we
tell people don't um buy a house with
your boyfriend or girlfriend because the
separation Isn't So Clean it's a
mess and similarly if you and brother
just go in as as brother and sister
boyfriend
girlfriend um just two people the
separation part is going to be a
disaster not to mention Are you
seriously sis you're going to make me
pay you back for your down payment well
yeah are you kidding me I'm your brother
you don't love me well yeah or vice
versa right and so or he's going he's
going to start dating someone and
bringing them to your house and she's
not going to like the way you cook and
dude I just I just wouldn't I just
wouldn't I wouldn't and here here's the
greatest way you can love each other is
to not go into a legally binding
agreement together see what I'm saying
right one if you buy the house and rent
it rent a room to the other one I'm fine
with that and and and do it right like
even when you do the way John said do a
lease like this is is it a year lease
let's just start with a year-to-year
thing right and and and do it by the
book so that at the end of the day if
something has to if the hammer has to
come down it's not it's not you doing it
it's the lease right you know what I'm
saying like hey the lease is up we did
say and you can always point back to the
terms of what you guys agreed on I'm not
going to lie I still don't love it but
it's your life if you want to live with
your brother I'm not mad at it um I just
went into it man that's all I can say um
at the end of the day I here's here's
also where I stand though with
purchasing a house there is a piece of
this whether it was let's say you didn't
have a a brother and let's just say you
were calling and your Hope was to get a
roommate to live in the house it bothers
me for somebody to own a home that they
can't pay for in full on their own
because like I said something can happen
and whoever is living with you moves out
and it could take you a longer a longer
period of time than you thought it would
to find a replacement and so now you've
got to be able to cover the mortgage do
you see what I'm saying so my goal here
is to get you thinking about every angle
of this thing and just with me poking a
few holes I don't love like I look I
want you to have a condo I want you to
have a home I want you to not be a
renter but I I want it to be done in the
right way my question for you next is
what would it look like and this is just
for you to brainstorm uh you don't have
to answer this now where you live is
really expensive what does it look like
for you to do the same type of work
elsewhere uh I can move I guess but uh I
feel like my current job right now is
really good like benefits wise I it is
but it's not allowing you to live you
want a home and it's not allowing you to
do that look I I have family who lived
in California for years and they're
married and at one point they said she's
a teacher and the other one you know
Works in gaming and they said we're
never going to have the life we want
here and they picked up and moved to
Georgia
yeah all I'm saying is you may have to
consider our hospitals need lab
scientists in Kansas City right where
you can buy a condo maybe for 300
instead of 600 or maybe 350 instead of
what and I don't know Kansas people are
going to be like you can't but I don't
know but all to say is you have to
decide which dream we want which dream
that's so true John oo that's a hard one
but she's got some options she's just
got to allow herself to see the options
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life